Hi youtubers it's Charlie and I'm passing
around flyers, please send a raven to ygritte
if you've seen this boy. She wants to talk
to him. or cut his balls off. I'm not sure
which, one of those two things.
So I'm actually rounding out most of the
surviving Stark children in my Game of Thrones
Season 4 previews. Although Jon Snow isn't
my favorite character on the show or in the
novels, none of my previews has mentioned
the wall or the north yet.
Here's a mild spoiler warning for Jon Snow,
The Wall and the wildlings.
I feel like Jon Snow and Robb Stark were almost
the same character, brothers from different
mothers. They both have this really strong
sense of duty that has really prevented them
from using common sense in a lot of critical
moments, but you get the feeling like if Jon
keeps doing what's right as opposed to what's
best he'll end up just like Ned Stark. That's
what being stubborn gets you in a game of
thrones.
So right now when Season 4 picks up, Jon Snow
has just made it back to the night's watch.
remember they still think he's a traitor.
They brush over it since he's near death,
but I think the rest of the brothers won't
let him forget it. They're not the nicest
or most forgiving group of dudes.
And for any torchwood fans out there Burn
Gorman has confirmed that he's coming back
as the night's watch brother that murdered
the lord commander and old craster last season.
They don't really address that the lord
commander's been murdered when Jon snow
stumbles into camp, but I think that Jon will
be forced to take control of the night's
watch by the end of the season.
Also don't forget that the raiding party
of Wildlings are still coming for them. When
Jon ran away they were on the path to the
Night's watch anyway, so I think they'll
have a battle within the first few episodes.
Really the wall is where most of the action
is at in season 4, so Jon Snow won't be
traveling around like he was in season 3.
It will be a lot more like season 1. The drama
is really in the decline of the night's
watch and their ability to defend themselves.
Remember all the characters there have spent
the last couple of seasons talking about how
no one cares about the wall anymore, they
don't have enough men to man all of the
castles, there's no food and most of the
brothers can't fight.
And they've officially acknowledged the
re-emergence of the white walkers and their
army of wights. There won't be any large
battles with them until at least season 5
I think, because remember, Stannis just decided
to take his army to the wall with melisandre.
That's a whole other story line I'll talk
about in another video. But mostly season
4 at the wall will be about Jon Snow taking
a leadership role. We kind of saw him making
his own decisions last season, like when he
broke his oath for sexytime. But in the books
it really seemed like the character just kept
getting colder and colder emotionally as he
started to take on more responsibility.
It's a lot like after Robb Stark started
the war against the lannisters, you didn't
see him joking around a lot after that. The
interesting thing is that in the story both
of the characters are still teenagers. So
when you picture Robb and Jon, they're pretty
much still in high school. I guess they missed
the class where they teach common sense.
Jon Snow and Ygritte will be reunited eventually,
but it will only be after the wildlings try
to take the wall. There are some really interesting
unintended consequences of the wildlings appearance
at the wall that end up changing the direction
of the story really dramatically, but I'll
talk more about that in my Stannis video.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Let me know what you think is going to happen
to Jon Snow though, is he going to end up
having to kill eegritte when the wildlings
attack? And will Stannis and his Army arrive
at the wall before the end of the season?
How long will it be before Jon Snow takes
control of the night's watch and becomes
the new lord commander?
I think all of the major events at the wall
in the second half of book 3 as well as book
4 will end up happening. Remember they're
changing the story a lot, so they will be
combining a lot of characters and events from
books 3 and 4.
My next game of thrones preview will be for
Brienne of Tarth. I'll post that on Thursday,
in the meantime you can check out my other
game of thrones season 4 videos by clicking
here and you can check out my review of the
first episode of sleepy hollow by clicking
here.
Thanks so much for watching, high fives!